okay hello everyone welcome to another
design review for orphan language
heading for version 13.1
and i gather this is the 600th
live ceoing live stream episode that uh
we have transmitted
um
that's an awful lot of time spent
reviewing open language put a lot of
work into it
um
and uh
uh
i it's always um
good to hear when when people appreciate
all that work
uh
but uh it's fun to do as well
okay
let's see what are we looking at today
we had gone
through many of these pieces we were
talking about we finished down here
uh arc through and special point data
had we not
and we were talking about oh yes we were
talking about
this interactive graph
layout and i had asked that we review
this
with some folks from
uh
ux
who and design
who are not here
uh so what happened with that it's it's
me
well
uh okay
um
it's it's it's it's the wrong time of
the day for ux people it's uh
ux people are on the wrong side of the
world for this meeting
okay well then we better reschedule the
spot
no but but that's why i'm here
okay that's exactly why i'm here
okay
all right
so how should i do this
i should say
i mean this is exactly can we at least
get see if jeremy is available for
design
okay so if i say random graph
4080 editable true
is that going to work
yes
okay
all right
so first point here
is this selection
wow what the heck is that
okay this is bonkers
right my what's happening here
why is my yeah
so um
you
uh
you ended up hitting the
resize uh
knobbies
um
at least i'm pretty sure that what
should happen here is when i click like
that
okay
i should just be getting the node
if i click again
i know what i'm getting when i click
again here
the way that selection works normally so
right right this is this is the generic
graphics selection and yeah you're
getting the the the reshape selection
here which is
just not what you want right so is that
fixable
uh
with a bit of work in the front end
um okay but that's what it is
yeah i mean i basically we just need to
enable an
alternative selection mode in a given
graphics that uh
uh
that removes the resize handles i assume
that we don't want resize handles uh
uh so i like i mean if you do a drag
selection on some
nodes or whatever i assume then you only
want to translate them you don't want to
resize them right yeah we don't want to
resize
the individual node
what we might want to do
as a luxury item
is to be able to double click
to go into a node to start doing stuff
with it
but the generic action program
well so define stuff what do you mean by
stuff
um
graphics editing in it i mean going in
and editing text and god knows what else
i don't know
i mean
uh
i'm saying
in um
well so i i mean there's a bit of a
danger there i mean you know imagine
these nodes are text you know and i mean
instead of being graphical entities
they're you know letters or something
like that uh and and then i mean you
know just in the same way that you
double clicked and you got into the
reshape tool
well you can double click and get into
text selection and
once again not be what you wanted okay
listen the single click should just move
the node around as a as a unique atomic
thing
okay
double click if there is something
clever we can do with that and it
requires careful ux thinking great but
that's a luxury item
yeah
and you know i mean this is this is not
i mean i see this issue even with you
know other illustration software it's
like you know i want to select the block
of text
you know as you know as a whole or i
want to select the text inside of it and
how do i distinguish my opinion that i
want to do ultimately what should happen
is
you click
and there should be some little knobber
knobber noblewade that comes up that you
could hit that would make give you a
menu of things to do but that's a luxury
item yeah and that's definitely not
happening for 13 watts yeah i know i
know i know so i'm not asking for it i'm
asking for this case
you hit it it selects the node you can
drag the node around
yeah yeah and and that's doable it's
just
going to require some front-end work
okay so what do you what should it look
like when you selected it
um so
well i mean my defaults uh
by the way also
a single click is not selecting the
single click is doing this weird thing
what the heck is that
uh
it's it's a graphic complex you can have
a group of graphs right you know we
we're not going there if you click one
of these things you're going to get the
damn node
we're not going there we're not going
into something where you're giving
footnotes about what i agree i'm just
explaining yeah
no one is no one is fighting you on this
stephen okay all right good you asked
for an explanation and you got one okay
um
but uh the sorry what was i gonna say
the uh
uh oh the the what should the selection
look like
my default would be to just
make it look uh
like it does now but without the
knobbies
uh
but i'm open to other
ideas
which is to say you know the the purple
i understand that it has a rectangle i
don't think that's obviously silly
did jeremy join us does he have a better
idea
just joined and i heard silly i didn't
hear the rest of it okay all right so
this is about um
uh graphics being able to do this
isn't that fantastic source yeah that's
great yeah
um
i've got several questions actually for
charles and so on i mean this is really
nice functionality to have this
but the problem is when you click to
select a node how should the selection
look
that looks like you could stretch the
node which
unfortunately oh yeah well you shouldn't
we want to disable that so
i don't think it needs that box
necessarily right that single center
mark maybe i don't think you'll be it
won't be enough you won't see where it
is
uh
there's also the issue of if you drag
select several nodes
um i i think you want to see the the
full box and maybe stephen you could do
that just so we can see it i don't think
you can because it's panning in that
case
oh it is okay
okay
yeah ignore me
yeah so so what do i do so i i select
them there so i'm selected i'm a
happiest i'm a happy person now how do i
how do i drag them uh i think if i
recall correctly i think you have to
drag on the ink somewhere
right so it have to hit the vertex one
edge
otherwise it no no no no no
yeah yeah
well that's magnificent except that it
was it required you know
uh 10 years of experience or something
to actually know what to hit
yeah well it's lovely
um
okay so that's the second case so so
what are we what is the analog here the
analog here
is i mean in a graphic it makes sense
because you're going to be able to edit
that piece and text
we just do inverse you know there's an
inversion color
right now yeah it's not always it's
actually never in version but what yes
well it's it's different on
fundamentally different windows versus
mac uh on
mac it is a highlight color that does
not change the text color at all
on windows in fact it actually
changes the text color so it's like a
blue background like a more solid blue
background but then the text changes to
white
okay
um
well
those could technically be images too
though right they could really be
anything for a vertex this is the
default but
yeah i mean but but
and in fact you've got to have something
that extends beyond the vertex you've
either got to put a wash on top of the
vertex somehow
or um
so one of the things i pointed out
before you joined jeremy was the the
very real possibility that their uh the
nodes could in fact be textual
they could be
letters or numbers yeah or words
well there could be nothing there or
they could just be the the you know
that's true yes that's true i say if i
do this thing here oops
okay now that edit case that case where
i yeah it's all right it's it did the
right thing because we had edited it
i'm not complaining about that so if i
say here
no er but but that raises yeah i mean so
uh that raises a very interesting
question um
good luck on me finding being able to
my 10 year experience is not enough now
to actually be able to select that note
so what i was going to suggest is a
possibility
is that the
we go with the rectangle but we draw it
with a little bit of padding around the
object
and then use a wash behind so you get
like a light purple background yeah i
think that's a good idea i think that
having having that border and then you
know a purple and then a washed purple
so to speak interior maybe a rounded
wrecked definitely no you know drag
corners
oh that's an interesting idea
could we do that around a rectangle yeah
will it look like a button will it end
up looking like that that's that's i am
concerned about that yes
i just don't want them to you know if
it's too similar to this it feels like
you might stretch it or you know scale
it
when
when you say
rounded you you mean it can like a
really tight rounding like yeah pretty
good i've got a different idea jeremy
what about a circle what about something
that is very rounded well
oh no
no no no no
how about a rounded rect with with a lot
of rounding if you get what i'm saying
well okay so so one of the problems with
that is that you might have something
you selected
that is now outside
the the rectangle or you have to buffer
the rectangle to
account for that
possibility okay i understand your claim
so let me understand what you're saying
so you're saying can we how do i make a
rounded rectangle uh you can just use
framed
uh framed of
of i don't know just framed of like a
graphic uh
and uh with rounding radius
make it uh 20.
okay
so
does this rectangle
if i
is there a configuration in which the
rectangle will in which the rounding
will slice off a piece of the actual
uh content or is it is the rounding
such that it is the rectangle is drawn
i see if i if i made it tighter
then this would eventually
chop off
i don't i don't remember exactly how
framed works in this regard it has
default padding so you'd have to remove
it to see it yeah but but yes you're
identifying the point that i'm concerned
about though i think it's frame margins
goes to zero
yeah
i see that's getting marginal at best
um
nice pun
you get rid of them yeah
and it becomes marginal
right
right
i think with the right coloring this can
be made to not look like a button and i
think having the continued rounding not
you know what i'm saying having having
more
rounding
will make it look you know because
because in the case of a circular node
what we really want is that this is just
a super node
you see what i'm saying
um
and the case was circular no it's
supernode well i mean i i just it's just
bigger than the node right it's just
it's just a an enclosing circle around
the node that is also circular
as circles are
okay but i mean
are we optimizing for that case i'm a
little concerned about that
i think
that the rounded rectangle okay so let's
take a look at what will happen there so
i mean you're saying if we take
a rounded rectangle and we say we we
have a graphics
how the heck do we do this um
how do we do this i want to well it yeah
it's going to be all the way around the
graphic uh
what i want to do is just a style
of a filled circle
yeah it comes with line spacing though
why not a graphics because because the
frame won't don't go to the side
yeah because the frame will be around
the rectangle of the graphic
okay so that's what we
end up with there and that's really
stupid
oh that's well because it should be
clear it's it's not getting its full 20.
i mean 20 is a really big number uh
okay fine but i mean in this
um
now it's getting its full 20.
yeah well so so the question really is
if we imagine that tightening in i think
that will be okay
um
oh that's interesting um
should take a look at
the example that brett
yeah
that is interesting
and and and it's general
can i can i bring up the drop shadow and
make it less
less uh ethereal so to speak
can i make it less
how do i make it the opacity of the drop
shadow
how do i change the opacity there
you can add the opacity to the instead
of purple you can't replace it with
opacity or pastel color no but i want to
make it
brighter i want to make it less
less
you know muted
how do i do that
so it's just a just a
four value rgb color right right
because
because
because the default because it by
default it's applying an opacity of like
50 or something like that so
i understand it i'm asking
if we made less opacity right
i'm asking how to make this
less specified opacity to you right now
you only specify the first three
coordinates for four value rgb colors
yes yes yes yes yes
so if i say opacity one comma purple
um
[Music]
so that's why
what
well i consider it more like
a bug on the support
okay can you fix that but that's just a
okay so let's do rgb color
purple is as
rgb
one right
yeah i don't know no one ever told the
front end team to support two argument
opacities so we never did
you should
there's
how do we make this brighter
you see what i'm asking i think it's a
good idea but how do we make this
stand out more
the option to do it as an exposed jet
give me a moment to now
okay give you a more complicated thing
but jeremy what do you think about this
general approach oh yeah i think it'll
work fine i i use this instead of border
often for shadows i i think i think it
still needs uh i i think it still should
have a border around it
but this can be done instead of the
background color though but so all this
assumed that you are selecting the
vertex what about the edges
this would work great on an edge yeah i
think it's about fine on an edge
how do i select the edge anyway oh i
need to go back up here
oh my gosh well that's really bad way to
specify the selection of an edge
right
it's very cartesian but it's not
otherwise useful
yeah but once you get two of them
then what choice do you have
you drop shallow both of them
why not
and then in other words as you wash over
something
you are
um
harry is asking is the edge actually
colored and the answer is well yes but
but it's awfully hard to see that
but i mean if i go up to here oops
whatever
uh yeah you were doing a resize oh i'm
doing a resize because i rather than
during the during the initial selection
process yeah okay so there i've got many
edges selected do i also have vertices
selected yes you have both
okay so there i go
but
right but this is essentially like a
constrained drawing story
this is quite lovely i mean this will
have a big effect on on a lot of random
pictures that we make
um
okay
i'm going to tell you some other things
i know people are going to want they're
going to want to be able to adjust where
the vertex label goes
i mean in general with labels they're
going to want to just move a label
around
the other question is when i get back
this graph
okay i think these can be fine
extensions for a future
great what was that oh yeah yeah well
i'm not asking for this for this version
roger
what's that
no i didn't put the expression back yet
so
it's just fitting
okay but that we do need
yes you will work
um
okay
the thing i was trying to do isn't
working for some reason so all right
fine all right so we we need to iterate
this again but but we got the basic idea
drop shadows we're going to go to an
edge now what happens if i've got
selected an edge
what what can i do if i select an edge
but right now you can move the edge you
can delete
the edge i think you can delete it like
above you just you know if you double
you select the edge
well i i i i i i think stephen's point
is
how can you do something with an edge
without also doing something with the
nodes at either end of the edge you
can't you can't i mean that's
right okay so that's so for right now
let's just select nodes let's not select
edges
um unless you think
what am i missing i mean that's the
expected behavior right when you select
the no no it's not no
no
no it doesn't matter what the look if
you select this edge the thing you'd
really expect is to be able to reroute
the edge for example
i mean what is the delete operation
anyway if i go here how do i delete that
node
press delete
no no we evaluate that that object your
object is now just a pure graphics
revalue the graph
random graph
so you should have a normal deletion of
an edge of everything sorry
now
but something is on your build normally
maybe it's backspace versus delete
no something is just wrong it's just
deleting the box instead of actually the
event handler something is wrong in the
event
in this case right and why i just want
to make sure that did you put in event
handlers for both backspace and delete
or just one of them
uh backspace
well that's not good enough
okay
yeah you need both right
well
well john we can discuss that later but
it was just mainly backspace which
worked
okay i mean
certainly on windows i would expect the
delete key to work and on mac and on mac
they should both work they both delete
they should both work and they sure
shouldn't do this i've never properly
understood the delete key on mac which
you know is often not there on many mac
keyboards
okay so that that case seems like you
actually end up selecting inside the box
maybe i just need to control how far do
you
make sure that the tag box get the
selection the full selection of the
object and just the inside look there's
clearly more to do here i mean there's
clearly something where we'll need an
attached menu and you'll be able to add
edges and god knows what else right
right so that's kind of a long-term plan
right now we're just planning to just
put a basic
graph
okay just just do what you have right
now move a node
delete a node as luxury
even delete the node is luxury
can you move with a single click
set the intent or do you select first
and then move no you should be able to
move with a single click you absolutely
this this is nonsense this this panning
is just nonsense no no no no no no no no
look you either support drag selection
or move with a single click you can't do
both
and there is also the scenario that you
are looking at the graph which is
connected here you know is is there are
cases where you can have this connected
component and you want to rotate a
specific component you want a larger
specific component so
look look look listen listen
there's a lot that could be done here it
needs an attached menu it needs much
more serious design
this is just
a simple version of this
but let's make the simple version work
nicely
okay and what jeremy is saying is do you
need to double click in order to be able
to move the node or even
single click single click i was guessing
that's what happens i mean you could
imagine if you have hover over you know
a node
no you know just drag could work that'd
be uh
yes but uh but the thing is
is you know even if
uh moving individual nodes is always
supported today that's not all we're
supporting in the future which means it
will change i mean you know fair enough
look i think single click is okay if on
hover it gives an indication that there
is a single clickable thing
um
um
you get what i'm saying
if if on
yeah so long as there's an indication on
hover i think it's fine it'll so the
cursor isn't is that enough it will have
a cursor effect
yes
if there's a cursor effect that isn't
this cursor which is well i mean the
obvious cursor effect would be
you know
either a you know like a uh uh you know
a four-way arrow or a hand you know it
is something that indicates that you're
able to drag it around that's fine i
don't like either of those pieces of
iconography but yes if we have a
reasonable cursor there it seems like
the right thing
then clicking is okay
yeah
look for this version what i think we
should do is just support that
just clicking and moving a node
i mean for luxury you can delete a node
what else what other actions would you
like to have
guys
charles
what other actions have you do you think
you've already put in
um
so you know
selection delete move
precise okay
let me tell you
i i just asked you we need a list of
everything you've put in because i think
most of them should not be there for
this version this will not be right yes
so that's the part i has explained john
at the beginning we have to understand
what is not actually that i put in
something specific
so if i can allow to actually explain
you so that we say is integrative graph
edit graph layout editor so what we try
to do
is essentially
to generate a graph
or if you look at it as a graphic and
let
the graphic editor behavior just work on
that graph i know that was the plan we
did so we can talk try to take off
things yes exactly
that's to take up everything yeah and
and that part depends on the front-end
side so they have to improvise right so
so so we remove reshape and we remove
resize
um and
nick is asking how would vertex resizing
interact with custom edge shape
functions
like what if the edge ends at a
particular point of reverse
and
you
don't
actually get complicated because an edge
can be a dis right how about we not
support vertex resizing for this version
i i think we're already agreed on that
yeah
okay fine
so the only thing we're supporting is
move and move a vertex
and delete them and and maybe deletion
yeah yeah those two would be fine
now
and and and implicitly selection
yes
let me ask this question what is what
about the
re-run
okay here's a question how much
hysteresis is that as in if i wiggle
these around if i move them around and
then i rerun the minimization code
the the layout code will i get the same
layout or might i get different layout
it's like those those things what the
heck was that thing called the
that thing with springs and so on and
and um right so it's not dynamically
adjusted no so this is just a pure
just think about it as a graphic so no i
i understand i understand but but you
are getting back the graph right so
given those initial vertex coordinates
you could rerun the minimizer on those
vertex coordinates
yes but what we will do if you move it
and just make the expression after the
whole cuff we actually embed the vector
scored in it so we do i know i i know
that i know that i know that but but so
what i'm saying is at this stage right
when i've when i've moved something
around
right i've moved something around on
this one here by the way this
interaction we need to understand
right with the canvas with these
editable graphs
um
yeah
yeah i i i i could do something
reasonable for well well i mean i think
the only uh
you know what you want to do is
essentially have it as a background um
yeah that's fine okay that's fine
for this version that's fine okay
sorry what were we just saying we were
saying oh gosh what were you just saying
charles before that
no you're saying that you we could in
principle run the minimizer with oh yeah
initial value right we don't do that now
we have prototypes from long ago when we
were thinking of building such an edge
okay so what i'm suggesting is this okay
i'm not suggesting that the once
produced once you've hit shift enter on
this graph you've got what you've got
it's got vertex coordinates burned in
what i'm saying
at least you know as soon as you've
moved something it's got vertex
coordinates
makes sense yes
okay so now my question is
um
uh what i'm saying is that there should
be something an attached cell type thing
or something that you can press a button
and rerun the minimizer while you're in
the state while you're in editing state
i see so use the
existing position has initial value in
the minimizer yes that's what i'm
suggesting that would be very useful
probably not for this version but but
that will be very useful let me try
something else here
uh how does it's oh god this is driving
me crazy that command l doesn't work for
this
is that really right john
command l copies down input cells
yeah
if you converted it to an input then
it's an input cell
all right
we're working on the mind reading stuff
but we're not there yet
this is pretty good this is pretty
responsive
how far can i go with this
um
it's uh the whole thing is uh everything
here is a graphics complex right charles
yep
justice um
so
i i don't have a
i don't
i mean it's dragging i mean i i i i mean
i can't i can't give you numbers to say
for sure but yeah i mean it's you know
this is uh in terms of the box
construction
it's efficiently constructed
uh
and
i i think we have a good story in the
front end for handling this and
we could probably optimize it a little
more but it's you know what what charles
is giving us is all is you know ideal
for these sorts of manipulations
okay
if we could get something that would run
a minimizer or even run you know be able
to run different graph layouts here as
and we got some ux for that that will be
magnificent
um
so
charles it's straightforward to
set up an attached cell interface that
could just you know pop up automatically
anytime you've selected a graph now the
content of that interface of course is
entirely up to you but
if you know
when you have something
you want to to hook up that's
that's quite straightforward
so i mean
we need that for for region it's just
that we you know we yet haven't had the
time and resources to actually build you
know one for graph i mean we have some
prototypes so we will
do that at some point
that feature would be just really useful
i mean i think what we want is something
where there's an icon which means re
you know re-minimize and there's a pull
down from that that allows you to pick
other
methods for the
layout
making sense
yes put that in the list
well and also giving you the feedback to
indicate
you know
what method is in use right now
possibly
you know
sorry
does that thing are you hoping to see to
move dynamically or you just want no i
don't care
i mean it'll be entertaining to move
dynamically but it's mostly
entertainment value to do that
i mean i would expect most of the time
because you'd made a fairly small move
you know you move particular vertices
right what's going to happen is it's
just going to relax to something
it's not going to be a big wholesale
change it's rarely going to be a big
wholesale change it's mostly going to be
the particular vertices will kind of get
pulled back into the main graph or
something
see what i'm saying
yes
i think it will be just fine to not see
the dynamic case
the dynamic case is pure
sort of you know that's amusing but it's
just not that important i think
um
i do think and i want to say that the
general thing of moving labels around is
really important but the problem with
that is
here's the thing that is a ux problem
that we need to solve okay so let's say
you move labels around and um
you you know prevent something from
colliding the problem is then i want to
regenerate the graphic and by the way my
labels go in a completely different
place in the regenerated graphic
so what do i do i mean it's very similar
to the calculus of annotations problem
when do i blow away the annotations when
do i keep them
yep and i suspect we should solve it in
a similar way i mean i think that that
again they'll separate me from i i'm
sorry is it solved or
for calculus of annotations yeah
somewhat i mean we're about to see that
actually you can can take a look at that
right now because we're about to see
that with graph sum and graph join and
so on okay
um
okay i think we're we're in a reasonable
place here um
uh jeremy can get you some specs i would
imagine for the um
uh and brett is gonna give you ways to
be able to give a little bit more
variation of the drop shadow and we
should be good from this
um
people are asking on our live stream for
lots of features that i would love to
see happen but they will not happen for
13 1 which is closing like
you know the train is leaving the
station imminently
um
they they will happen later
uh freezing portions and re-routing
portions yes these are all highly
interesting beziering the the edges
highly interesting but not for 13 1.
the 13 1 we're going to get the most
basic thing which is moving vertices
which is already non-trivial i also want
to see what it feels like to have this
editable true mechanism for doing that i
think that's a correct option name given
our other uses of editable right
uh
yeah
seems right to me
yep
um
yeah i mean you i mean you could make a
counter argument against it but i
wouldn't
no i don't think we need to worry
will there be an option to convert the
graph to a mesh that we manipulated
not quite sure i understand that
um
we already have a lot of stuff for
dealing with meshes okay let's keep
going
guys anything else charles roger do you
want to raise anything else with respect
to this functionality
what can we keep going no this is the
beginning not the end so right it's a
good beginning
very nice stuff
but let's just not over claim for it so
to speak i mean we're just
it's just moving nodes that's the whole
story here
um
that's a nice effect by the way
uh a
drop shadow effect i think is
gonna be uh
the one of the superstars of 13 one
yeah amazing how those things work like
like rounded rectangles and things
um
yeah i wonder where else we should think
about using it
i wonder if there's some well anyway
i mean i wonder about the height
rounded rectangles are just making it
into q t
okay
but but but listen in terms of highlight
graph and things like this
we should certainly certainly have some
examples that show drop shadow effect
that makes sense
um yes we can add some yep the highlight
functions should should show those
okay spatial graph distribution didn't
we look at that last time yes yes
okay we're just looking at graph sum
yeah which i think i understood and i
think i understood that that doesn't
that has no
annotation keeping is that correct
just blows annotations away
just look at the source
yeah okay
and there's no choice about that
blowing annotations the way that is
well at this time yes but you know we
we could preserve some annotations
right
but graft join better preserve
annotations
okay graph sum okay so first point i
think last time we were objecting to the
name
and you were telling me this is the
standard name for this
yes
and what we were saying is
these graphs okay wait a minute
you're saying that the sum is by index
number
that is if the nodes are called a b and
c
those are not what get combined it's the
position in the index list
correct
it's better say that but much more
clearly in this documentation
that's a very obscure way to say it
it's very obscure should say that the
things are ignored if that's really true
and is that really the right thing to
ignore the names of the vertices
just seems wrong to me it just seems
completely wrong to me if i was making
this if i was doing this graph some and
i had you know flows between this city
and that city okay and i wanted to
combine you know people going from
sydney to to you know london or
something right with people going from
there to there and i combine these
freaking graphs and i get completely the
wrong thing
because you know one of these graphs
might not have one of the indices in it
i don't get it i don't see how this is
useful
let's say that this graph had indices
one two three and four but this graph
only has indices two and four
then those indices will drop down in the
index graph on your toast
no it's it's it's resolved essentially
the key i the key idea here really if
you think about it the same has you know
people you build your laplacian curve
and such right you are manipulating the
adjacency matrix
right you take the adjacency matrix you
add a diagonal and such
so
what people wanted is to formally define
those operations
right so we call it graph
sum right i need to operate on adjacency
that's the whole idea i i understand
that but i don't think it's the right
thing at least it's an option perhaps
for graph some but the much more common
case how do you get the thing that i'm
describing is it graph union or what
do you understand what i'm describing
did you understand what i was describing
so i'm saying i have a graph a goes to b
b goes to c
c goes to d for example okay i wanted to
sum the flows
on edges yes i want to sum not not on
the edges i want to make new edges right
then i have an a goes to b
you know c goes to e
c goes to
c goes to b or something i don't know
okay now what do i do with this do i say
can i say graph union
yes
okay with vertex
is that the right way to do it
um yes
stick to arguments
okay so did this do what i was talking
about what i wanted
um well i'm not sure exactly what you
wanted but i just want to combine
i want to throw all the edges so it
unified the two a arrow b edges into one
it looks like is that what you wanted
that's wrong that's not what i wanted
that's not what i wanted
not so what you want but i want two
edges there
there are two edges i want the two edges
there right so you wanted to count the
multiplicity of the edges
well you would say it that way if you
want to but that's what i would think
that graph sum would do
not some crazy thing with adjacency
matrices if i wanted adjacency matrices
i would ask for adjacency matrices
okay
i i don't get this i don't get it maybe
there's some definition of graph sum i
don't get it it just seems like a source
of bugs to me
that first of all somebody will have
something which is dense and then graph
some will work then they'll have a
sparse sparso graph and it'll fail
no graph some work on all
no it doesn't it does the wrong thing
they'll think they're going to get the
thing which
k takes in other words as soon as they
delete a vertex from the second graph in
the graph sum okay all the vertices
after that vertex will have their
numbers adjusted and they will
incorrectly align with vertices in the
first graph
agree
like you see all your intuition correct
it's possible but what we are adding
here is a well-defined operation right
so we can decide to drop it because we
don't like the behavior of the operation
but we
that's the operation
is it the operation so if i look up
graph sum on the web
i will see something which says it
renumbers the vertices
conveniently our very own website
you know as i pointed out before right
there is the case that you know most of
the graftery and some of the operations
are on on label graph
in the language we did with label graph
so to reconcile it in some case we just
have to get rid of the levels and then
you end up with the indices
right
so that's pretty much what we are doing
we cannot live in both worlds in the
world of labeled graphene unlabeled
calves
except for trees we're doing the exact
opposite we barely have unlabeled trees
yep
yeah sandra is commenting that what i
want is graph of the join of the edge
lists yes that's right but i mean which
maybe is the right answer for that
is graf son a common operation
so stephen is the result of what i put
in chat what you expect or not
you know as i said right those
operations appear like when you do
lactation graphs even right the
laplacian graph is what the adjacency
matrix plus the diagonal matrix yeah
right so how do you represent them is a
graph sum
simple as that so that operation appear
when you do
you know or you construct other objects
right and if it's not the most standard
one you deal with but it appears i mean
people use it
but why
in that example
the diagonal happens to span the whole
matrix
right
but what if i wanted to take a graph
and insert like a green's function from
a graph for a graph okay so let's say i
have a grid graph
[Music]
okay 1010 grid graph
and i want to insert in the middle of
that graph i want to insert another grid
graph right here
okay how would i do that
because if i do a graph sum
if you want to insert i mean so that's a
graph transformation i mean the
graphical writing you pick a vertex for
a node and then you
define your transformation rule
you shouldn't assume that should be half
sum graph sum is just adding
okay so it's adding on a corner there
that correct i don't know why it did
this whole thing
did you expect it to do the thing it did
here
yes so actually those are the first the
the starting vertices so there should be
five of them right
so
you know then you get that multiplicity
it's like you're adding two grid graph
and then the rest remain identical
something is fishy here look
i don't know how these are numbered
maybe we should put in the numbering
here
so what's happening is
this is friggin weird okay so what it
did was it grafted
that grid graph there
onto
this
oh that's so freaking weird it grafted
it onto the right-hand edge because of
the numbering here right
right so the way you can look at it you
take the smallest graph and then you
have the big graph you just
map them on top so you're adding
adjacency matrix
right now is what happened at the
beginning there so
it's pretty much at operation
this operation is going to lead to a lot
of bugs
why don't you just compute the adjacent
matrices and add them
what is this can preserving in the graph
other than is it blowing away
annotations
no at this time you are not supporting
annotations no i understand so so that
means this is exactly equivalent to the
one liner of add the adjacency matrices
correct
um
white is a little bit more than that
what what more is it
well you have first to convert them to
index graph and then add the adjacency
matrix and then call adjacency cuff on
it if you're hoping to get a one-liner
so you have to canonicalize them to
white on
graph from one to n and then construct
yeah i know i know lb is commenting
another definition of the sum of graphs
the smallest graph that contains all the
arguments as sub graphs
right
and that's not the graph union either
given n graphs
what graph contains all those graphs of
subgraphs
what's the smallest graph that contains
all those graphs of subgraphs
charles does that make sense
it's clearly an answer to that question
i mean it's clearly a different
i mean no no that's a definition
that this person is is making of a graph
some
um
[Music]
okay do you understand the definition
the definition is you take a bunch of
graphs and you ask what is the smallest
graph of which all those graphs are
subgraphs
presumably either labeled or not
um well my first intuition i doubt that
is correct it may be one of the property
but i doubt that is correct
but what's correct what are you saying i
mean the question is the claim is not
that that's the same thing as the sum of
the adjacency matrices
um
[Music]
so i'm saying that that's a different
definition i mean i you know
the question is the definition of graph
sum
do we have it right
yes
ah
nick comments that he's been doing some
implementation of graph product
okay
without knowing that there's other work
being done let's take a look at next
it could join us here if he wants to
we have got production version
so just for your information
this growth product
yes version 10. well it's not just it
was not just in the system contest so
that's pretty much it
what else is not in the system context
what else i mean is there more graph
stuff there um
possibly i mean there is
on top of my mind i don't have the full
list on top of my mind i mean we didn't
we didn't go live with these because
first of all i think that there's a
there's a lot of graph products for
instance
that are potentially really interesting
and useful
um
um
i mean they didn't make it for a reason
at the time that didn't seem the most
compelling i mean among the you know 100
also function at the time it was not on
the top of the list at least
okay this is so of next
work
wow
that's a lot of graph products
yeah there are a lot of them
sounds to me like nick and
and um
charles should interact here
okay
and my question is which nick is also
asking now
i mean nick
asked it more clearly first
is aren't there lots of graph sums just
as there are lots of graph products
same has there's a million of graph
operations everyone can define those
right
so what we define is you know what's the
most common on what people we see people
use right yeah but but okay let me be
very practical
if you have a two argument graph sum you
at least have a fighting chance of not
getting tangled with that
right just like graph products you're
doing a two argument graph product you
could have an energy graph product
right but you're not
but you are having any graph some i
think that if you make it define it as a
as a binary graph sum
then you can put in that third argument
all these different things about whether
you re-index it whether you do all these
kinds of things
you know you might want some default for
right now for the two-argument form but
if you make it an argument from the
beginning you're kind of toasting
yourself forever
you see what i'm saying yes
so i would argue if you make it binary
we're probably okay
i think graph join should also be binary
okay
and i mean if you know we can
my only question is the other graph
operations like graph union they are all
is graph union and real just binary
um
probably an away it's followed the same
as our union so
yeah but there are plenty of
well i would make these binary
i mean i'm not
thrilled that
this is a bit of a mess because it's
basically
a potentially energy operation although
maybe some of these things will tangle a
lot if they're an array
i'm making sense
i don't know how tangled these get i
mean it's like like join across for
example which you could imagine an
energy version of join across but it's
already complicated enough in binary
what
i mean because as roger pointed out i
mean we we had this operation for a
while and that was one reason why at the
time we decided not to push them and we
wanted to actually see how people use
them uh you know all the requests from
thousands it turns out that they don't
so far as we can tell because nick for
example didn't know it existed
it didn't
no no what i mean is that we didn't
release them in the system contest we
wanted to see you know suggestion but
nobody would know that they were there
no but people the question is did we get
a lot of requests for them for them
and it didn't happen yeah right
well we seem to have at least one fan of
graph
uh graph product here
naturally we got several i mean there
have been several people other external
people requesting for graph craft
products
so
that's why we decided to move it to the
system contest okay well fine okay so
what i'm suggesting is
two graphs one you know subsidiary
argument which doesn't yet have to be
defined for graph sum are you okay with
that idea do you think that's sensible
okay
roger do you think that's sensible i
think it's okay
i need to run unfortunately i'm already
in deep trouble here so
well we'll review the rest of this
without you i guess okay
talk to you
bye
taking off also see ya
okay does this follow basically the the
function repository entry
of the same name
right just to put in context you
remember we had the physic uh i mean it
was on your request from the physics
project
yes i think i
exactly so we are going to the list of
those constructors i'm trying to
introduce them as requested
good
i mean i'm not objecting right so
my only question is here the tourist
graph i think i'm
should this be called taurus grid graph
or is this actually a taurus graph no
it's it's a c
it's a cycle it's a product of cycles
yes
white
yeah balance between both names so it's
um
i just picked up because it's the
shortest one
but yes we could call it also taught hit
calf
no tourist graph is probably better
what do you think taurus grizzgoff
taurus
are we going to get going to get in
trouble with pure tourist graph because
we're going to want something else to
mean that
hard to see what else could mean that
other than this
right and i think that uh
toro's graph is a specific case right of
this family i mean the one people see
which
family no i mean this to us graph right
it's
you know
it's a family but the tourist graph you
are thinking about is like the you know
the third example there where is it you
know you actually see it embedded on the
toggles is kind of what i mean
i'm sorry i don't understand they're all
look all of these are a grid
isn't it the case that these are all a
square grid
that have had edges identified nodes
identified to curl them into tauruses
yes or no yes
but what i mean that when people say to
host graph they tend to also think about
the embedding which we don't the vertex
code did it which we don't add here by
default if you see what i mean
i understand we might but i
what is this i mean this is a grid graph
and there are different ones as as we
can see here for the hexagonal
see then this will become taurus
hexagonal grid graph
i kind of think we should do that i i
know it's a little bit ponderous but i
think i think it is more accurate
okay
i mean what do other people think
anybody else who has an opinion
we have other people here right
we didn't all get
but they may have opinions about just
because you're not here for this meeting
doesn't mean you can't have an opinion
about this
yeah i think it should be taurus grouped
off
okay
and now a hexagonal grid graph
aren't there many options for this thing
i mean having it in its basic form is
already a good start
but i still think
you know there's options about whether
you put
yeah you see there's options about
whether you do this or whether you have
tried to have it
be as vertical as possible right
yeah i could move that guy over to here
see what i'm saying
right
and i thought there were options for
this in the rule plot stuff for cellular
automata
i thought there's a way of doing this
that was defined there
okay i you know this is a good stop i
don't think it's the right thing okay
there's a good start and we can put it
in
as an experimental function but i think
we need to you know have a little bit
more development here
right do you understand the point i'm
making
white yes
there's a version of this that is as if
square as opposed to a parallelogram
like this
so i'm saying and if you look at rule
plot
if we can bring up rule plot where is
rule
what happened here
why is that you know john i think that
when i've been pulling up
windows they are
for the last version or two with some
probability they're coming up behind
what i'm looking at
am i making sense
john are you still here
well then who's
yeah yeah can you hear me yes yeah sorry
i just i threw you to the loudspeaker so
i wouldn't have to keep wearing my
headset um
um
that uh sorry that the help window was
is coming up behind otherwise i'm
finding a bunch of windows are coming up
behind what i'm looking at
but that's been happening for a version
or so
is what i was saying
no comment at this point
oh i think it's a bug i've been meaning
to report it
okay so this is this question about how
these bricks look
and um
look let me show you this
oops
what i want
do i want i want this
and that
oh my gosh that's a bug
oh they don't really want bricks but but
then what i want
this this case is handled here let's see
parents are hexagons why role play
because
it doesn't do it with array plot
see here
those hexagons are stacked
with your parallelogram
and this is the way this this is how
lattice plot
for example works
this requires a bit more thought okay
the way that lattice plus works is again
you know it's it embeds in a square
do you understand what i'm saying
charles yes
yep
no i think you know we
we're looking at it you know in a
precise way i mean so if you want a more
general function we can work on it and
extend it
yeah
i mean isn't it the case
any lattice
defines a graph right
that's how the lattice works and does
lattice data allow you to generate the
graph
no
why not
um
at the time we didn't have graph
and i i didn't come back
and update it yet
okay well fine but i mean it's of
lattice data okay look look we've got
several different things going on here
okay and ed
peg is a good person to
to look at this because he worked on
okay so we've got these lattices and the
issue is can we make the graph from
these lattices
yeah we can easily make we have the
bases we know how they are built
right okay so that would that would be
very very lovely to have
right the general lattice now now we've
also got in the function repository at
least we've got a lattice plot
yeah we should be able to have
you know arguably to make things cleaner
we should have some kind of lattice
graph
see what i'm saying
because any one of these lattices will
make a graph right
yes
and it's kind of like making a crystal
you just say the lattice graph and you
give
you have to say the number of root
vectors right is is you have to give the
dimensions in terms of the number of
root oh that's it you know whatever it
is in terms of the number of root
factors yeah yep
i kind of think that's the function we
should have this lattice graph and then
you say hexagonal gum or whatever
okay we're gonna work on that and see
right
and maybe we can put um
i think taurus grid graph is useful
i do think that the mixed taurus case
where
you give
you see what i'm saying where um
uh
you know what i'm saying where you
specify
uh some edges are
yeah there probably should be another
argument here that specifies which if
it's taurus grid graph
you see what i'm saying there's a lot of
freedom in in how the matching works
yes
right so if you do that you can make a
kind bottle if you have
right so what you want is
you're
either you're either not knitting
that's just flat you're knitting
cyclic
or you're flipping
clawing bottley
isn't there a way of representing this
in terms of permutations or families or
permutations or groups or something
jose is jose here maybe
um see the question i mean so i mean
what we've got we've either got identity
on a given edge
it's either
it feels like it's either none that is
don't connect them or identity that is
take the list of edges from one side
and
you know look i think naively it would
be
maybe i'm wrong none
or identity
or reverse
but i'm thinking that perhaps this is
just an apology and not the geometry
so there is a difference there i
understand do you think there is a sense
in which we can distinguish one side
from the other side
of a surface here or something like that
ah
you're right
well we've got a grid graph right and so
the grid graph by definition has
coordinates
because we've got a grid graph in which
we say
the first coordinate direction is the
length blah the second coordinate
direction is of length blah
well we have a graph with an embedding
but i'm not sure
the graph is more like a topology the
embedding has a geometric some sort of
extrinsic geometry
no but what i'm saying is if literally
all we're doing in the graph the level
of the graph is this thing has tentacles
presumably
it has two tentacles here
right it's an extendable grid graph
with tentacles on every
every piece has tentacles
right so then the question is
and this relates to the hairs in
graffiti writing
is where the tentacles go
you can look at it as a quotient
operation where you pretty much
identified the two side right
so from a flat sheet of paper you can
build the torus by just identified
the two side
so that's how do you characterize that
identification
well these things have would have
different topology and then there are
these um homotopic groups etc these
poncare groups that
can describe
yes topology
robert are you saying
i mean that's a finite group
somewhere
and
how would you apply that finite group
okay make this creature into a klein
bottle
which you can clearly do right you twist
the two ends you identify these two
sides but with these two ends twisted
right
am i right is that the correct thing
if i do a mobius strip here okay how do
i make this to my biscuit answer i just
do this but i identify i mean here i can
mobilify this
all i have to do let me let me mobilify
it in real time
um
okay so to murmify this i would simply
say
um how do i add edges i just say graph
union right
or if that can do something stupid
is that correct charles
well if you want to add that you do um
edge add
i want to add multiple edges can i do
that
um yes i think so
okay so i want to add
to mummify this i want to add 3 goes to
19
i want to go 2 goes to 20.
1 goes to 21.
and do i put these in a list
yes boys
okay and if i say
uh
graph 3d of that
well i probably need a longer one to
make it clearer what the heck's going on
but i think this is correct isn't it i
mean this isn't this isn't very useful
because it's
crosses over like that
but you you see what i'm doing yes
yes
but but for me this is actually distant
and at least that's my view is that this
you know graph uh terrorist graph have a
precise construction this has a set of
transformation which should be a
different function
where we can give that freedom to you
know have all those constructors and
modifications yes
okay fine all right fine taurus graph is
a useful thing
that's fine
i understand these these are getting
hairy is your basic point
that this but but just for my uh
edification i mean this modding out by
something what are you modding out by to
get this
do you understand my question
um yes
well i'm right i'm looking at it as
well not on top of i i can't see that on
top of my head but if you do the vertex
identification you can pretty much write
it as a mode operation
right so which is i would think so it's
an equivalence class it's basically
defining an equivalence class of
vertices yes
i see the right way to think about this
guys yeah look look this is the way to
think about it the right way to think
about it is simply
i mean equivalencing vertices
this is not right what i should have
done is define these vertices as
equivalent
right here i'm adding extra tentacles
here but we could have just said
equivalence those vertices
so it's kind of a graph reduced by
equivalences
and
you've got
vertices go ahead yeah the same as you
take you know the interval 0 1 you
quotient you know i mean the square
right you question both sides
appropriate topologically then you
create a total subject
yeah
no but what i'm saying is the operation
that we want on graphs i'm claiming
is one where we are
defining certain
vertices
as equivalent
we're reducing a graph by some
equivalence relation
yes
which i don't think we have right now
and that seems like a useful operation
to have
in fact that operation is one that we
would have used in the physics project
if i didn't thought of it because that's
that is an operation that equivalencing
thing
yeah that's an interesting operation
ah nick is saying vertex replace will do
identification
so just replacing three with 21 or
something
although it seems
yeah but identification is more than
that right it's you know
vertex replace will identify it but it
doesn't
i mean are you contracting the vectors
the edges and such i mean depending of
how you identify there is also a
subsequent operation on the edges which
have to be defined
right in this case this is kind of a
glowing operation
in this case it will be more than by 18
every vertex
right let's have this as a separate
discussion we can put this into ild
discuss it there seem reasonable
but taurus graph seems fine
i kind of think the hexagonal one should
be a function repository item for now
and i think we should go for this
lattice graph idea
that makes sense charles
yes
i really like this lattice graph idea i
think that's really nice it's a good
leveraging of lattice data and it will
as you say be rather trivial
but it should be totally trivial from
what we have in that scarf lattice data
yes yes
let's do it maybe we could even do it
quickly
um
okay let's see how does one save an
arbitrary infinite graph asks
lb
uh it's complicated i mean we don't have
the notion of infinite graphs yet
we don't have infinite lists we don't
have infinite graphs both will be
interesting
um
inc
asks and to circle circular and
hexagonal sections of hexagonal grids
regularly numbering the indices of
hexagonal sections is easy you just add
rings of vertices from the center
hexagon
numbering the circular sections is more
involved
wow okay
that's interesting
sander talking about tauruses with a
twist
where the where the twist which such
it's not periodic in one round trip but
after several round trips yeah so it's
like the mobius strip that's been
you know where the piece of paper has
been twisted multiple times but that
that just it's it's mod too isn't it
am i totally confused no i'm not totally
confused it just goes back to the same
thing
am i right
help
come on somebody
well it's not just mod 2 because you
need to flip the object to fight
here we go
let's try it
yes i see i see you're right obviously
obviously it's like a knot
knotted multiple times
ah yes my pathetic 3d visualization
sense i have to actually try it
um
okay i think that's it for graph theory
is there anything else for graph theory
charles
oh no that's good oh we forgot buckyball
graph
oh we talked about that a little bit
last time
is that well defined
um
yes it's well-defined
these are useful
i mean there's an argument that this
should just be in graph data what do you
think
i think it's useful
well the only argument is that graph
data is finite right so this kind of
gives you the freedom to generate the
family of them arbitrary family no but
graph data has non-finite
graph data has parameters does it not
no as far as i know yes it does
well i think we cannot generate a 10
million vertex half white
well that's a different issue
that wouldn't need i don't know why you
know you guys are just allergic to
having the right people in these
meetings
where is graft data
oh this version is probably
well whatever so let's let's get
my gosh this is not exactly a small
function
my gosh
okay what's a family of graphs anybody
know a family of graphs complete class
good good suggestion
look there you see kaylee
kaylee tree for example
three five okay let's try kelly 336.
i believe it can generate families of
these things
no but what i mean is that i doubt that
you can
put an arbitrary number
no i i i understand
i'm i'm disputing that
i think you can and you certainly
in general i think
eric likes pre-computing things i'm not
competing in real time pre-computed
that is a really bad error message
that's really bad for five different
okay
this isn't lcc discussion can we get
eric in the next lcc meeting we'll talk
about this
okay seems wrong to me
yeah i can bring that up i'm a little
concerned about this buckyball graph if
if i mean
where do we draw the line
i mean graph data has just a zillion
graph types here
am i making sense
yes
well last time is me was actually
arguing that you know if this is
gravidator it should be part of it and
we're more pushing for this
i mean i think it's a matter of
importance what do we think people i
mean will commonly type or want right so
if you think that buckyball is that
important then we i think it's fairly
common but i in so uh you know you could
argue so some of these other graph types
i mean i don't think it's it's
cognitively damaging to have essentially
graph special functions
which is what we're talking about
you already have here family of them
right cycle graph complete graph star
graph
and maybe we should have a lot more i
mean maybe that and maybe they even can
come from
essentially graph data and many of these
infinite families could then just be
special function graph special function
functions
all right let's put in the buckyball
thing and let's have the discussion with
eric about other ones and can somebody
at least check this with eric please
that he doesn't like freak out we're
doing the wrong thing here
okay i'll make sure this gets by him
okay
thank you
all right
time to
go to
segment b we're not going to get to
segment c astronomy today i don't think
um but we will get to trees hopefully
um
and i think we can get a slot
tomorrow
unless i'm completely confused i think
the 245 eastern
meeting right now that i have could be
moved out of the way in which case we
can continue um
we could do astronomy then i think
astronomy is going to be a somewhat long
meeting do you agree jose
um potentially yes and and there is
another meeting which is perhaps more
important which is this change from
data globe to map box and i would really
like to have that as soon as possible
okay so if we can have that tomorrow
instead that would be great
is that a long discussion
no that's short that's quite short okay
well maybe we can do that at the
beginning like 2 45 then we can then we
can spend 15 minutes on that then we can
go to the rest of it yep that sounds
great
okay
okay
trees where's the agenda
so there was um the original
uh agenda prepared by roger
but i think this time we wanted to
review some things that you suggested
uh in the previous meeting
and that yeah has implemented in the
external
sorry sorry sorry um
is there an agent sorry i wasn't i lost
concentration for a second because i was
looking very distant in agenda
okay fine
you see that's the problem as soon as
i'm looking at email there's a thousand
other messages
more than a thousand 2 573 to be precise
just in the middle of working on
something which is causing me to be
further and further behind
okay what are we looking at here
which which was the section here we were
looking at sorry you were just saying i
wasn't playing we were kind of jumping
around last time we started looking at
expression tree
and
things to do with unlabeled tree
and so i have some updates
okay okay so where should i start here
um so this is the prototype
yeah i'm running this in prototype build
so do a random tree and
[Music]
uh
apply unlabeled tree to it
oops that's not what i want
ah that's not what i want either
unlabeled tree is new right yep
that's nice except that
could we get an option easy an easy
option hey i don't do i do you really
like that of having these
is that what we do for graphs
no so the default
tree
uh size
is fixed
no no no no but i understand but for a
graph
we don't maintain is is is charles still
here
um yes i'm here
okay but we don't for a graph we don't
see this
if i make the smaller
the nodes scrunch down and that's what
should happen for an unlabeled tree
okay that's wrong
let me put some code in chat
what do you want me to do with this
what do you want me to do with this
i put two things in chat
okay
so one of the things you wanted was
in the case where there's no labels you
wanted the nodes to be smaller so here
i'm just using the default graph shape
so that should work exactly how graph
works i think this is right i mean i
don't see any reason to
you know you can see it's a freaking
leaf
right now okay you actually can't in
thirteen one um we're distinguishing
between an empty list and none in the
second argument empty list is always
round
none is square
and only the square ones are leaves
so you can actually end up with trees
without any leaves now
comments from other people i i like this
idea
i think this is a little bit too light
and that's a graphic design issue
can you look in this in the first input
style equals there's a darker construct
currently i'm using 0.3
well i think
and i just put a third input in chat we
need to make sure that that darkness
also works for the labeled case
wait wait wait wait what do you mean
also works
no no no no you should not do the same
thing for labeled and unlabeled
you shouldn't do the same thing that
darkness will not work for the labeled
case well we said last time that we
needed to find a compromise that worked
for both
well i don't remember that okay
it would be very i think it would be
strange for the style to change
that's not going to work for the labeled
case so do we have somebody from graphic
design yeah
no
jeremy's still here
okay
jeremy wants to try to pay attention
again
yep
okay so let's see the tree
without
oops
okay that's our default tree
okay now here
if i remove the tree element style
here
what happened to the tree element style
underneath the tree element shape
function
i removed it
no also remove the tree element shape
function
although i'm quite liking filling the
nodes in the case where there is no
value for the nodes you see what i'm
saying
in the case where there's no
in the case where
okay here
we've got numbers for all the nodes
right
as soon as we don't have numbers i don't
see why we're not filling the darker
color
i think it looks kind of stupid to have
these things well how how is this going
to interact with
actual options like if you specify red
or is it going to make a darker red for
unlabeled ones
i don't know
i mean how does it interact with options
for a graph
the labels and the styles are
independent
well you mean labeling as in
removing a label won't change the style
of the node
okay okay
let's let's figure out what to do here
so you understand that the objective is
to make unlabeled trees
i don't think that looks very good for
an unlabeled tree i think it'd be better
if the thing had something filled here
but you're going to say what if it's is
this a is this a what if it's a
cautionary label tree function or for
any tree that's unlabeled because
unlabeled tree itself could set whatever
options we want if we want to no i know
that i know that which might be a good
solution
because i think if if you have a tree
which is otherwise labeled but something
is lacking a label this is a reasonable
way to render it
see what i'm saying i just think if the
whole tree is unlabeled what do other
people think it doesn't look
particularly good to me it looks like
see the problem with this is
there's lots of lines in this picture
and there's additional lines here but it
isn't really a line it's just a point
does that make sense to anybody
it does i thought it was a bug at first
although maybe i'm confusing the didn't
we have a green kind of a medium green
for nodes for we do
that's the
well i can't even see it there
i mean it looks completely white to me
but i've been told that this is green
it's green on my screen
but it's really much too light for a you
know unlabeled i agree it needs to just
go darker or more open or less opacity
can you really not see this
on a screen
really
why don't you screen capture it and
let's see if it's green screen capture
it and send it to us and see if we see
green i mean whether it's your monitor
being badly adjusted or whether it's
just a
you know some some other kind of
you know
you can see the green what's that i can
see the green
but i have a mic i already know
i see green as well
but jeremy doesn't see green i bet he
has a nice fancy monitor i i do it's
it's there but it's barely there
for me
yeah okay
i think that's sort of okay for this but
as you say it's not okay in this case
here exactly yeah
and so
stephen i just emailed you a screenshot
from me
i suspect it'll look green for you it
looks green
it's green
i sent mine too
you know bizarrely these screenshots
look different
okay this is really this the world is
just falling apart you know
okay
that's that's ian's screenshot
this is jeremy's screenshot
well i that's with the edge form applied
no i understand but look at the center
this this is much darker green than this
one here
jeremy's doesn't look green at all
they're both white
oh for goodness sake
do you understand why this is this
because opacity is not being handled
correctly on all these different
displays
i don't set an opacity so i'm not sure
okay
all right so look
okay the first thing we should do
is when you say unlabeled tree okay i
think the correct answer is when you say
unlabeled tree we should reset
the
the um these things
to have both
no
you know no square leaves
have you ever seen a tree with square
leaves
um
i unfortunately lilly pads don't grow on
trees so you don't even get circular
ones either but so can can you real
quick can you do tree of empty list and
tree of none and compare those
you know that should not be that big it
should resize just like graphs do
you should use the same
code as as some
as graphs do to determine their overall
size
does that make sense
for for this case for the labeled case
it's trickier because
the the data is not resizing and the
the frame is shrink wrapped around it so
so unlabeled tree of a single none it's
just going to have to be circular
and the circles should be like they do
in graph they should resize the size of
the object
for the unlabeled tree case
now given an unlabeled tree
it returns just a tree but with a bunch
of options set right
yeah options removed or set if necessary
right but not able to returns a tree so
all of the things that i can do where i
ask for the uncle of the uncle of that
node will work
we are also removing the data do you
want to keep the data
of the nodes
so because i was thinking that perhaps
this is more like a structure tree it's
another tree that represents the
structure of the previous tree and then
we can use
any new type setting
you mean
give me an analogy like an expression
tree for example
is another type of tree right because
labeling for example there are cases in
which we want to eliminate labels you
wanted for example that lists
the head list that never appears we just
put a small circle
so that there are these nested lists
cases in which
we don't want to see the head list many
times
nobody's ever going to figure out the
okay unlabeled tree unfortunately has a
mathematical definition right
yes but it's it's a it's a tree that
with with with no data that's why we
remove the data too
yes that's right because that means that
the equivalence classes will work
correctly with an unlabeled tree right
exactly i think there's a different kind
of tree i agree with you there's another
kind of tree
that
shows only structure
well
i mean if we preserve the structure from
the previous tree to me those are the
same what i was thinking is a tree in
which we preserve the data but we have
options saying do not show the labels
no i i get it i get it i get it but that
what i'm saying is that's a tree
okay
it's not unlabeled tree unlabeled tree
is what you're making it which is blow
away the data so that the equivalencing
works correctly
does that make sense
yep
but there is a different construct which
is a convenient way to take a tree which
has data in it
but where the data is not
shown with labels
where you could re
we could recover the labels
i'm making sense
unlabeled tree the labels are gone
right
correct
it removes the data
if there are any options then it
specifies none for the labels and if you
have an association it gets rid of it
okay fine fine fine fine so you're
saying there's another type of tree or
another
option another wrapper
yes
about maintaining the structure yes
that's a possibility
um
uh
okay
i should go soon here
um
okay let's let's come back to this all
right so we need a color spec for this
okay
so that's that's the thing
and we need
and i think let's see this unlabeled
tree operation
okay so it could take a second argument
yep
now you should say removes all data to
make an unlabeled tree
to make an unlabeled tree you get what
i'm saying yes
i like that wording
um
okay so the second argument
or is it an option like you know like
the directed edges option
of lots of you know grid graph and god
knows what else
was it directed graph or undirected
graph that had a second argument it was
a string
i don't know
is there one of those maybe charles can
say
um sorry what was the question
so directed graph has a second argument
where you can specify a conversion
right
i mean yeah there's several ways to
convert a
graph to a directed one
that's nice
so it's basically no data
feels more like an option you know
preserved data but it shouldn't be
called that true or false
um
are we calling it data anywhere
yes is that what what where data is the
function that extracts the data and we
call it the data
i mean we could have an option include
tree data arrow true or false
or is that silly or are there going to
be other ways of unlabeling things
yeah i see there's also this um
if we include the tree data should we
have square
boxes for the for the genuine leaves
that's what i'm saying
if they're not shown
then i think the answer should
they should either
have the squares and for leaves in both
cases or or not in both no no no no
listen to what i'm saying i'm saying
let's say we say include tree data true
or false
for unlabeled
tree
okay
so in one case the tree data is gone
right
so
in that case
the question of of circle versus square
is about three children
not
well okay so we've got these two
different orthogonal things
what would you call them one is whether
to include the data
in the structure
and the other is whether to display
leaves in a special way
the second one seems like a different
shape function option
well we're not going to need
whatever
nobody's going to understand how to do
the shape function thing
all right so look
we can have a function like unlabeled
tree that sets a bunch of options
we're having a function unlabeled tree
so the question is whether that thing
has a second argument or does it have an
option
that says include tree data
i think let's prefer a second argument
that essentially is like a collection
collection of options of existing
options
except for this one about the conversion
which isn't going to be
i mean what are you going to call the
second argument you know unlabeled tree
and then what's going to be keep data
that's not a very good second argument
am i making sense
you know data included i don't know
what's the second argument going to be
do you have a suggestion
maybe the second argument's a true false
no way no no no no
should be a string but
yes it's difficult to choose the name
that's why i'm proposing include tree
data true or false as an option
i mean that option could even be in tree
in general and it could just drop the
tree data if the option is set
so that unlabeled tree becomes the
equivalent of
no that's not right
you're saying setting the option would
delete all of the data
no it doesn't make sense
from what i know now i prefer that
option
i don't see a good way of naming the
unlabeled tree converter but if you can
come up with a good way that would be
great
okay and we need a spec for this so i
don't know if jeremy has one or it's
going to get one or what the story is
here
okay what else can we look at quickly
how much stuff is there here let's get
story about that what
we need to look at all of these options
and we added a ton of
second arguments to expression tree
okay
well let's look at the things that are
simple tree leaf count
that we
had a property wait a minute that's just
a function right tree leaf count yes
okay
where's the new documentation
this is it
no i mean but what aspect of it is new
all of the
definitions and notes
up here or down below
the the usage messages and all of the
notes that you see there in the
illustrations
this is completely new
what did it say before was it just
incomprehensible
pretty much
great
wait a minute successor applies after
the data of each leaf up to level n
adding at most n levels to each leaf
there's a two different meanings to n
i don't understand that
look look here it says applies f to the
data of each leaf up to level n
okay period that's one thing
that's the top of the tree then it says
adding at most n levels to each leaf
which seems completely wrong
it's just completely nonsense
i mean they're essentially just the same
statement twice
but that's nonsense it's not adding at
most n levels to each leaf it is
no it's not it's going down
at
no you apply the function you apply the
function to each leaf
in times giving
a tree a tree of depth in
where each leaf was
the thing there is that it could stop
earlier so that's why it says at most
okay so if i take
a random tree
five
so the most obvious thing to do is nest
tree
f comma percent 54 comma
two
okay i understand that
like i assume that's the first example
you give
oh god no
just give this bringing example first
but if
f is supposed to return a list
in general
if it returns a scalar it assumes
basically that you mean the list of that
scalar
right
all right well maybe you should do it
with f and g first here
like the second example
yes maybe
i don't know
okay so this is i see to the leaves of
the tree
there's nothing it does until it gets to
the leaves
it's just recursing through until it
gets to the leaves
so
if i say nest tree
of f of this thing here
and i want to start it from the null
tree can i just start that from none
well that's not very good but but okay
so from x for example here
okay that's nice enough
so how does that relate to nest graph
so the
operator
works the same way but in nest graph the
functions being applied to every node in
the graph
i hope that's an example in this tree by
the way
i'll make sure yeah okay
okay
okay and that's three-fold
are the examples
they're closed
by the way brad clee has an interesting
analog of treefold for dags
that's directed acyclic evaluate
yes
have you been looking at that has he
been talking to you about that
it's on my
list okay i don't think the names are
actually a cichlid evaluator is right
but i believe it is basically the analog
of of treefold for a directed acyclic
graph
which is interesting in my opinion
is this new uh i think i think i
understand roughly how that would work
but i haven't looked at his
code in detail
i think the one of the issues is how the
payload is is maintained in a in a graph
as opposed to a tree
right but with a graph this is some kind
of like annotation
computation thing one would assume we
should ask him about that
unless there's a representation of of
dags that is more like the
representation of trees
um
yeah avery why do you want me to save
down title one notebook
um
it doesn't really matter
it could be in the trees or graphs
folder
this graph folder right there
yep that should be fun
thank you
okay
both the data of each sub tree and the
list results for its children
where's an example of something real
being used for this we're being for this
being used applications
so what's this doing
this is just getting nested lists out of
the tree and then it moves on to showing
how you can do things like total the
data in the leaves total all the data
some entity query
[Music]
i see nest tree returns a tree
and tree fold
uses the tree like fold uses a list
exactly
in what sense
treefold
uh is basically a homomorphism from some
algebra to the algebra of trees
and nest tree is a homomorphism from a
co-algebra to the co-algebra of trees
i'm not sure that helps me particularly
but yeah okay
roughly lines up with what query calls
descending and ascending operators
so nest tree is a descending operator
treefold is an ascending operator wow
are we finally going to actually have a
meaning for the ascending and descending
business of query that we're working on
so i mean there's an internal function
that nest tree and tree folder both
implemented with that has both
descending and ascending operators but
that's
not for third party
so there's going to be so potentially
wow so you could have something which
will be the the generalization of query
for operations on trees
it
because of its generality it's not
limited to trees
it's like
anything that's tree-like yeah
yeah like an expression for example
there's a internal page if you want to
look at it what is it called expression
transform
it's not really it's not really ready
for it
i'm loving because that's just such an
unbelievably generalized you know
it's an unbelievably general thing
it's not a great name though i don't
think
to me the important thing of this
function is that it separates the list
of ascending and the list of descending
operators which are mixed in query
so this clarifies
quite a lot
is it well defined you do one first and
then the other or how does it work
you do all of the descending in order
until you get to the bottom and then you
apply the ascending ones as you
backtrack
but so is that what query does as well
but it just doesn't tell you that
well it alternates
so you you get either a descending or an
ascending operator per level
right but the difficult thing is two
separate lists
but how do you know in your way of doing
it that level three is going to get an
ascending operator and level two is
going to get a descending operator
so
every level gets both a descending and
an ascending operator
but you don't have the notion of levels
in your thing
well so it's like f zero f one f two
that's f zero gets applied at level zero
and then f one gets applied at level one
f two gets applied to level two okay but
so you have to specify so so so what
you're doing is
we're proposing an association syntax
it's not implemented to where you could
just say level two this operator level
seven this operator and i see i see i
see but you're saying that query
on a given level
can you have only one of ascending and
descending
or can you have both
well uh so uh
you they you can use a composition
it looks at the composition and looks at
each of the operators in that
composition and will
decide what you know it'll do the
descending ones while descending and the
ascending ones while ascending
so you can kind of
specify both
in in what in query query but you're
proposing that i see so there's nothing
theoretically i wouldn't use the
proposition syntax for that in this
function
and you could have a composition that's
just the entire thing is a descending or
the entire thing isn't ascending
instead of trying to parse it apart yeah
no i get it i get it i mean but
basically what you're saying is
that there's nothing array theoretically
that prevents one from having
combined ascending and descending on a
given level
in a certain sense it's impossible to
avoid it's just the other
it's like if you if you think you only
have a descending it's because the
ascending operator is like the identity
yeah yeah but but it's very difficult to
predict which one it is and for a given
operator
query and dataset will have an opinion
this is always descending or always
ascending well i understand we can have
examples in which the same operator can
be placed in the first list or the
second list and the results are
different
right i understand can you scroll down a
little bit in the basic examples
the saprinsky
i think that's nice
so you can see it's really not like a
tree thing
it's a nested structure thing no no it's
somebody never construct a tree at any
point in this it's a very nice construct
it's a very nice object it's it's
basically a generalization
it's some kind of generalization of map
all or map
in which
i mean map
just wraps an f around everything but
what this is doing which i don't yet
fully understand
compare this with map
so this is actually so map doesn't
the map doesn't use the evaluator and
this does
um this is in the in the nest while and
fold family i think
but
okay with nest while and bold is their
list like
um
but in
nest graph and nest tree you have this
thing where if the operator returns a
list then you go into the elements of
that list
and so my claim is when you do that
you get
nest tree and tree fold basically
okay
there's lots of properties and relations
with like bold and
stuff that's very interesting it's a
very interesting construct i mean this
is this is probably
you know in the future of a raised
discussion this is probably one of the
the lost array operations
indeed
yep
um
just in terms of map though what is an
ascending
i understand your point about map just
sprinkles f's
return
if map was immediately evaluating
if it was
then i think it would be an ascending
operator because it's a bottom-up depth
first traversal
yes
yes and that's that's really all the
descending and ascending means is you
have a depth-first traversal
it has a top-down portion and it has a
bottom-up portion
and the question is do you apply the
operators while you're traversing
top down
and do you apply them
okay so what happens if you change the
traversal order
i don't think this works with different
traversal orders
really
you need the results from your children
in order to apply the operator
so this is a question of having
different operators and in which order
they are evaluated because sometimes
when you do total you have to evaluate
first
those elements that you are going to add
and that
those were in deeper levels
so total is naturally ascendant
while there are others that you first
take a list and break it into parts and
then proceed to the elements so those
are naturally descending
i get it
yep
all right but that's a custom meeting
about this looks very interesting
okay so you've got expression tree and
then what are all of these
the labeling and styling and so on is
this new here
so the new thing is that tree is now
essentially fully implemented you can
have
uh associations of children
and list and none are properly handled
they weren't
quite handled properly in all corner
cases question in the case of
associations like that can you
explicitly label the edges
yeah so by default it's labeled with the
keys but if you specify label it
overwrites that
oh i see so so if i look at this tree
weird
okay
all right so those are on top of those
edges is that really how we want it
i guess we don't have any choice but
that that isn't that seems like it
hasn't had graphic design applied to it
that's correct
i wonder if we could use that drop
shadow business on this i wonder if we
could use a background drop shadow
to kind of
melt out the edge there
do you get what i'm saying
um by default or
so what if you said tree edge label goes
to c would the c also have a drop shadow
or would you need to specify it yourself
with a manual label
i would think it would have a drop
shadow by default i don't i don't know i
mean if if jeremy is still with us
i am i think that works until there's
i don't know are you going to get a lot
of density at any point where
the drop shadows add up to too much you
know obscure too much
not sure i don't think so because trees
do have the feature that things tend to
avoid each other yeah i mean
that sounds good it was just kind of
like you said soften the edge
underneath the label yeah
so i mean yeah uh please
ian why don't you look at it and i think
we'd want to by default
for edge labels there
and you're saying if you give an
explicit edge label
what does it do i mean isn't there an
edge label style and so on edge label
function and all that kind of thing
we're we're adding all of the tree edge
styles or all the tree edge options in
13 one there's a list
on the left
okay
good
okay these don't look too horrifying
those
gel coordinates yeah those don't look
too horrifying those labeling and
styling things look like they're
are they horrifying is that something i
should really
so the two things to point out are
you know
vertex shape function and edge shape
function
take a vertex name
but the tree versions take data in place
of a vertex name so
do you agree with that hold on
um
anything just sent some
how to get all the nodes in a tree
what's the most efficient way to get all
the nodes in a tree
what's the answer to that
so if i say random tree
and i just want to get the names of all
the notes how do i do that
tree level probably
how would i do that do i just say tree
level
tree level of that comma
all arrow data
ah
splatterroom
that's terrible
i mean there should be something let's
do all the
lists of all of the sub trees
exactly but so so right you see this is
where things get crazy because it's like
this this is we need something that's
the analogue vertex list
i think that's tree position of tree
comma blank
like this
what do you know
there you've got it
that's the answer to ethan's question
that has
that is a bug
i mean it's a bug
it should be returning the sub trees
i was expecting to get trees into which
we would then map through data
well okay but i think whatever this is
it's useful
to be able to get the tree leaves i mean
that's why we have extended level specs
in tree levels so you can say arrow sub
arrow subtree or arrow data
and what about three data with a level
spec of minus one that would be clear
right i think yeah i think so too well
we took away level specs and position
specs
okay i just did tree leaves and it gave
me the same thing which i'm happy about
that's what i'm saying is a bug
this is a bug
something is going wrong with this yeah
so so that should be little little tiny
trees
so if i map tree data over that then i
would get this yes
as opposed to this with sublists
correct
okay tell me the thing you were saying
before about tree element and tree
whatever
the thing you were saying before that i
should pay attention to this feature so
so
vertex shape function and edge shape
function
are graph options where one of the
arguments that they take is a vertex
name
yes the corresponding options for trees
um take position specs instead of vertex
names
because they're called tree element
yeah well because there's not there
aren't vertices i know that but they
don't use the term vertex so i think
that's okay
the tree edge what does it take
the thing that corresponds to a vertex
most closely is a position i know so i
think that's fine that's the argument in
the shape function there but but what
about the tree edge shape function what
does it take
does it take pairs of positions
yeah the first argument is the points
the point coordinates and the second
argument is the data
we mean by point coordinates
like the list x1 y1 x2 y2
well those are absolute x1 y1s or what
yes however it works in edge shape
function
okay
so an element shape function the
arguments are the xy position followed
by
the vertex name
that's that's the thing right
okay that's fine if that is replaced by
well but now in tree element you've also
got the data right
so are you feeding that into the tree
element shape function yes
okay but but that's different from the
way that it works for
yeah this is three arguments
okay whereas vertex shape function has
only two arguments is that it's also
three it's also three arguments but i'm
just replacing the vertex name with the
data instead
it's the so i'm using the same
arguments except replacing vertices with
data
that seems right
no except replacing the vertex names by
the positions
right so on the left hand side of the
rule
is a position
oh i see i see in the arguments of the
shape function
are the coordinates and the data in your
case or
the
name in
this case in the shape book the shape
function case
that seems right to me
okay
and then the other thing to point out is
that we have function versions of
options that that graph doesn't and so i
want to make sure that they're working
as
like what
all of the other ones on the left that
end in function other than shape
function
so we have label function style function
size function
why do we have those when graph does not
you should perhaps have those
i'm sorry i think you've suggested some
of them for graph before but i'm not
sure
we should discuss that
i mean you can achieve all that with the
pattern right
right it's more important
yeah that's all right
go ahead and
yeah so
in graph you have
the vertex names so you can have a
pattern replacement rule where the
labels and styles and things are just
given by transformations of the vertex
name
whereas
but for trees we don't have vertex names
so we need access to those
data somehow so you could say like tree
element label function goes to head and
it'll essentially apply head to the data
to generate the label
okay in the case of graphs with vertices
you're saying that the list of
of
labels could be
a list that's of the form
vertex name arrow what the vertex label
should be
yeah you have a pattern that matches a
vertex name
i understand why can't you have a
pattern that matches a an element
position
in principle you could but that still
doesn't give you the ability to have a
function applied to the data
applied to the data
so all of these things are functions
that that take the data
so this is a simple mechanism for saying
i want all the labels to be f applied to
the data can you also have a list of
rules that both select by position and
then decide on the on the on the thing
okay
that seems reasonable to me all right
let's look at the
uh
so the next place i guess open the
expression tree page and start looking
at
okay you did this okay
i i really should get going here
so we were looking last time at xml and
notebook
where is all that stuff so yeah scope
so the main problem is there's tons of
data in these nodes
and
we need better default visualizations
for them so this is my first iteration
on that since our last meeting
okay but i think we also need a lot of
options for the notebook thing i think
it isn't just one name here
do you know what i'm saying
that's what i said last time i i don't
think it should just be one thing called
notebook i think it's like notebook
import it should have several i mean i
think notebook import is a good model
for this
directly an expression tree
or are you thinking like a notebook tree
converter
i'm not sure
not sure i was thinking an expression
tree because i think that we can start
off with a bunch of name things and
expression tree
yeah so we just added the heads option
which works for the arbitrary
expressions like head trees heads
so
i guess we could have options in
expression tree that only work for
notebook i don't think it's options i
think it's other named things not just
notebook i don't think notebook is going
to be useful i think you never want that
there's no obvious default for that
the thing you have there is not a
particularly useful thing can you can
you mouse over the nodes
i don't care
i don't care that's not the right place
to put it
it's just not the right place to put it
look the thing that's going to be useful
is similar to notebook import to see an
outline of the notebook in this form so
again it's going to be kind of arbitrary
it's going to be things like section
headings
with um
uh
you know with an elided part of what of
their content those kinds of things
i mean
the unlabeled tree
okay so this is the case of
take the whole thing and make it
entirely into a tree but i see what
you're saying about yeah it just doesn't
you may want to have patterns or
whatever to make
it's complicated
i mean
okay so now let's say expression tree
of
uh evaluation notebook
no book yet of evaluation notebook i'm
sorry you have to do notebook gate
and then here
i say comma notebook
yep
yeah i don't know how useful that is i
don't think labeling it with cell cell
cells is all that useful i think
it's complicated because we've got this
cell cell group thing and it's it's
always going to be it's like a bipartite
tree type thing right
yeah so in particular the the hierarchy
here is not the same as the the actual
rendered
cell grouping hierarchy
you know like
you have a section cell hello and it
looks like it has a child
that's the two plus two
but in reality the hello cell is a
sibling to
the two plus two cell okay so so look
what we really want here is something
which is a representation of what you
think it should be
right in other words this isn't
particularly useful
look at how notebook import does it
because it's much more useful
right this is going to take significant
work to make this useful and this is not
yet useful
i don't know what xml looks like i mean
the the um
i also suspect that these will end up
being their own separate functions
right so i mean this should be an import
from a website or something you should
be able to get it into a tree
look you should be able to get it into a
tree do operations on it as a tree and
then emit it again
without it complaining that oh you don't
have the right header and this place and
this thing and that thing
um
[Music]
okay about my sentiment here
okay we're gonna have to continue this i
don't know how much of this is really
gonna get wrapped for 13 1 this
expression tree stuff i mean it'll be
good to have something experimental in
there but i don't think we're going to
be able to finalize it but let's keep
pushing on this
um
and uh pick this up tomorrow or soon
seem reasonable
yep plus you have something else for
like two minutes here do you want to
look at text element or data set or
trace
it's almost lovely but there's just a
lot more work to be done in these
i mean there's some very interesting
stuff here no question there's
interesting stuff
i i think this needs its own
proper review meeting and and when you
do it okay so we're gonna need other
people like for the trace one we should
have nick for the um
data set one
um
not sure but for the and the xml and
text structure where's text structure
what's text structure
above xml
i don't know
i just don't know
i don't know
i mean if we're going to go that far
afield with text elements
then some of these other ones could be
much more
uh
you know
you're referring to the manning yeah
yeah
much further afield there
um
okay
well
all right to be continued i mean we
should look at these but this will take
a whole meeting just looking at these
these things
and we should make sure we have people
who are you know knowledgeable about
these particular subject areas
sounds good
this is very nice functionality there's
great stuff right then and and this i
mean this really
it justifies the whole tree's
initiative to see all these things
coming together so it's all good but
take more time all right see y'all soon